Okay let's, let's summarize this. What are all the things that UML can
provide for you in state descriptions? At the top is the word tracking, that's
the state label. We can have the entry action, we can have the exit action.
UML supports the ideas of internal transitions. These are, you can
think of these as self transitions without the entry and exit actions. Okay,
UML now also supports the idea of activities. So we have actions and activities.
The difference here is that you can think of actions from the point of view of
the system as being things which are instantaneous. Typically that means that
we're turning something on or we're turning something off. And the time that it
takes to do that doesn't play in the rest of the, rest of the system.
Activities, however, are things which take time. Okay, the key word there is do,
and we're calling some kind of method which is going to take some time.
So we're going to be in this state while, while we're following the target. And
deferred events are a a, a special situation in,
in UML in which the set of events that the system is responding to are,
are queued, that is, put into a queue, and only processed at a later time.